en este ejercicio nos dicen que la
función g está definida sobre los
números reales y la siguiente tabla nos
da algunos de los valores de g entonces
aquí tenemos algunos valores de x y sus
correspondientes valores cuando los
evaluamos en g y nos preguntan cuál es
una estimación razonable para el límite
de ge de x cuando x tiende a 9 por la
izquierda recuerda que cuando tenemos
aquí esto cuando nos dicen que x tiende
a 9 con este signo menos arriba no nos
están diciendo que estamos aproximando a
9 con puros valores negativos sólo nos
dice que la x se aproxima a 9 pero con
puros valores menores que 9 entonces
aquí lo que tenemos que pensar es cuál
es una estimación razonable para el
límite por la izquierda de la función g
en 9 y aquí en esta tabla tenemos unos
valores de x que se aproximan cada
es más a nueve por la izquierda me voy a
fijar en estos valores de x que al
parecer escogieron específicamente para
que podamos analizar cuál es una
estimación razonable para el límite por
la izquierda empezamos con 8.9 un valor
más chico que 9 y luego nos acercamos
cada vez más a 9 con 8.99 y 8.999 se
están acercando cada vez más a 9 ahora
aquí enfatizamos que quieren que
encontremos el límite por la izquierda
usando puros valores menores a 9 no
quieren que encontremos el límite en
general si quisiéramos estimar el límite
entonces no sólo nos tendríamos que
preocupar por los valores menores a 9
sino que también tendríamos que
preocuparnos por los valores que son
mayores que 9 querríamos encontrar el
límite por la izquierda
el límite por la derecha y sentirnos
suficientemente seguros que ambos
límites por la izquierda y por la
derecha se aproximan al mismo valor pero
en este ejercicio solo estamos hablando
del límite por la izquierda así es que
vamos a analizar los valores que tenemos
empecemos con x igual a 8.9 y su valor
evaluada en g es menos 5.0 1 si nos
acercamos un poco más a 9 con x igual a
8.99 gx es menos 4.83 y si nos acercamos
todavía más su valor es menos 4.81 nada
más de observar estos tres valores me
parece que nos estamos aproximando a
menos 4.8 entonces parece como que el
límite por la izquierda se aproxima a
menos 4.8 pero eso no es algo de lo que
estemos seguros muchas veces los límites
si son números que se ven bonitos como
este
- 4.8 pero a final de cuentas el límite
claro que podría hacer algo por el
estilo ve - 4.800 45 el límite no
siempre se tiene que aproximar a un
número bonito ahora en este ejemplo
sucede algo muy interesante que es que
ok por la izquierda nos estamos
aproximando a 9 y los valores de g se
están aproximando a menos 4.8 y
empezaron en menos 5.0 1 pero el valor
de g en 9 es menos 5.3 entonces aquí
estos valores se están alejando del
valor de g en 9 y hay muchas personas
que con este detalles se confunden el
límite es el valor al que se están
aproximando estos valores y no
necesariamente es igual al valor que
toma la función en ese punto por lo que
estos valores se pueden estar
aproximando a un valor que
distinto al valor que toma la función en
ese punto por lo menos en esta tabla eso
es lo que parece que está sucediendo
entonces cuál es una estimación
razonable para el límite por la
izquierda cuando x tiende a 9 deje de x
vamos a ver qué opciones nos dan menos
5.3 yo eliminaría directamente esta
opción es cierto este es el valor que
toma la función en x igual a 90 si nos
fijamos en estos valores no aparece como
que se estén aproximando a menos 5.3 de
hecho se están alejando más bien parece
como que nos estamos aproximando a menos
4.8
empezamos en menos 5.0 1 pero entre más
nos acercamos a 9 más nos alejamos del
-5 y más nos acercamos al menos 4.8
entonces yo eliminaría esta opción y
luego hay menos 4.8 y este valor me
gustaba desde antes de ponerme a ver
estas opciones
que parece como una muy buena estimación
pero veamos que nos dicen las demás
opciones 4.7 que pensamos al respecto
bueno pues esto más bien parece como una
trampa al principio uno dice oye está
muy cerca del menos 4.8 pero no porque
no tenemos menos 4.7 si si tuviera un
signo negativo por aquí tendríamos que
pensarlo porque está muy cerca de estos
valores pero como no tiene signo
negativo 4.7 está muy lejos de todos
estos valores estamos hablando del
límite estamos preguntándonos estos
valores a dónde se aproximan y éstos no
se están aproximando al valor positivo
4.7 tendría que suceder un salto muy
grande entre estos dos números reales
entonces no creemos que el 4.7 sea el
límite por lo menos eso es lo que nos
está diciendo nuestra tabla y
definitivamente tampoco nos estamos
aproximando al 9
y nada más están tratando de confundirse
porque en efecto la equis si se aproxima
a 9 pero estamos hablando de la gtx a
donde se aproxima y como podemos ver más
bien se están aproximando a menos 4.8 y
con respecto a si existe o no el límite
por la izquierda bueno pues no podemos
tener la certeza completa pero lo que
nos muestra esta tabla es que parece que
si existe esta podría ser una función
rarísima que justo entre estos dos
valores cuando nos acerquemos ahora sí
muchísimo al valor 9 podría hacer que
esta función empiece a oscilar o hacer
algunos saltos raros así es que no
podemos estar 100% seguros pero si nos
basamos en lo que nos dice esta tabla es
razonable pensar que el límite si existe
entonces yo también tacharía esta opción
y definitivamente me gusta esta opción
que tenemos por acá pero bueno vamos a
hacer otro ejemplo como esto
un estudiante hizo una tabla para
entender el comportamiento del límite
cuando x tiende a 3 de fx aquí tenemos
el límite completo de f queremos
encontrar el límite por la izquierda y
queremos encontrar el límite por la
derecha y verificar que ambos se
aproximen al mismo valor basándonos en
esa tabla que podemos decir del límite
por aquí tenemos a x aproximándose a 3
por la izquierda aunque también
podríamos decir que estamos aproximando
a 3 desde abajo estamos aproximando a 3
con valores que son menores que 3 si
estuviéramos viendo esto en el eje x
todos estos valores estarían a la
izquierda del 3 el 2.9 nos lleva a menos
1 punto 28 el 2.99 nos lleva al menos 1
punto 42 y el 2.999 nos lleva al menos 1
punto 49 entonces parece que nos estamos
acercando cada vez más
al menos 1.5 cuando nos aproximamos por
la izquierda pero incluso aunque el
valor de f no esté definido en x igual a
3 el límite puede estar definido de
hecho esta es una de las cosas más
importantes acerca de los límites que no
importa qué valor tomen en una equis en
especial o si está definido o no el
límite puede existir pero bueno en esta
tabla parece que la función se aproxima
a menos 1.5 cuando nos aproximamos a 3
por la izquierda pero ahora veamos qué
pasa si nos aproximamos a 3 desde la
derecha si nos aproximamos a 3 del lado
positivo tomando valores que son mayores
que 3 si tomamos 3.1 la función es menos
1.8 si tomamos 3.01 es menos 1.63 y si
tomamos 3.001 es menos 1.51 entonces
incluso cuando tomamos el límite x
derecha cuando nos aproximamos con
números mayores a 3 el límite parece ser
menos 1.5 así es que esta es una
aproximación razonable basándonos en la
información que nos da esta tabla pero
tenemos que tener mucho cuidado porque
no podemos asegurar nada más viendo los
valores de esta tabla que el límite en
efecto es menos 1.5 podría ser algo así
como menos 1.5 187 con los últimos dos
dígitos repitiéndose infinitamente el
límite podría hacer este número aunque
generalmente en los exámenes de cálculo
está todo previamente diseñado y
calculado para que los límites tiendan a
un número bonito generalmente no vemos
respuestas como esta pero quiero que
quede muy claro que los límites también
puede entender a números como este
incluso puede entender a números
irracionales por ejemplo un límite
podría atender a pi sobre 2 no
necesariamente en el caso de este límite
pero en general los límites pueden
tender a cualquier número real pero
bueno tomando la información que nos da
esta tabla esta estimación es bastante
razonable veamos las opciones a ver cuál
nos convence más el límite cuando x
tiende a 3 de fx es aproximadamente
menos 1.5 si definitivamente creo que
esta es una respuesta bastante razonable
yo si le ponía una palomita a esta
respuesta ahora en realidad no sabemos
que esto sea cierto existen escenarios
en los que la función tiene todos estos
valores que nos da esta tabla y aún así
el límite no existe aunque estos valores
nos hagan pensar que si puede ser que
cuando nos acerquemos todavía más al 3
la función empiece a saltar puede ser
una de esas funciones que justo cuando
está tan cerca del 3 empieza a oscilar
oa dar saltos extraños o aproximarse de
un lado hacia un valor y del otro lado
hacia otro valor y que todo eso suceda
en valores
más cercanos al 3 así es que no podemos
estar 100% seguros de que pasa esto pero
aunque no podamos estar 100% seguros
esto es algo bastante razonable dada la
información que tenemos así es que
podemos modificar este ejercicio para
que diga que cosas razonables podemos
decir del límite pero bueno siguiendo
con las posibles respuestas aquí dice
parece que hay una cinta en x igual a 3
pero no parece como que haya una sin
tota lajas into estás aparecen cuando
uno de los límites por la izquierda o
por la derecha se va hacia menos
infinito o hay un finito y por aquí
estos límites no se están yendo hacia
infinito ni a menos infinito entonces
podemos tachar esta respuesta conforme
nos acercamos a x igual a 3 los valores
de fx se aproximan a 1.5 pero no podemos
asegurar que ese sea el límite
exactamente así
y esa respuesta está muy bien es justo
lo que estábamos diciendo por acá parece
como que el límite es menos 1.5 en la
mayoría de los exámenes los ejercicios
están diseñados para que nos den números
bonitos que no estén tan extraños pero
en realidad con la información que
tenemos aquí no podemos asegurar que el
límite sea este podría estarse
aproximando a algún otro número un poco
más interesante pero incluso el límite
podría no existir esta podría ser alguna
función muy extraña que cuando nos
acercamos a tres lo suficiente cuando
nos acercamos a menos de una milésima de
distancia la función tenga miles de
saltos o incluso esta función podría no
estar definida en todo un intervalo
alrededor del 3 tal vez no está definida
en 2.99 99 9999 y tal vez tampoco está
definida en 3 puntos 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 1
tal vez los límites laterales dejan de
acercarse al mismo valor así es que en
realidad no podemos asegurar nada por lo
que esta respuesta es una excelente
respuesta los valores de fx parecen
oscilar saltar para arriba y abajo cerca
de x igual a 3 por lo que es difícil
decir cuál es el límite o si existe no
definitivamente no estamos observando
ese comportamiento en esta tabla por lo
que yo no escogería esta respuesta no
estamos observando esto en la tabla
claro que siempre podemos encontrarnos
con una función muy extraña que justo
oscile en un intervalo muy cercano a 3 y
tal vez si empezamos a agregar valores a
esta tabla si empezamos a tomar valores
mucho más cercanos a 3 observemos este
comportamiento pero eso no es algo que
estemos observando en la tabla que nos
dieron por lo que yo no escogería esta
respuesta